he arrived at 320 in a gray tesla
he was wearing a face mask when he got
here as he went into the building
there's a muse just behind the hospital
here so he didn't go in through the
front entrance
as you wouldn't expect him to and he
stayed
for about 40 minutes before leaving just
about five minutes ago
it is unusual because he hasn't visited
his father in hospital on previous
occasions
prince philip has come here a few times
before in december
2019 he came over consider
again as a precautionary measure he
didn't get any visitors then he stayed
for four days
i think you know the other concern is
that family members and hospitals
generally isn't happening at the moment
family members aren't allowed to visit
uh people in hospital generally um
so it is an unusual thing that uh prince
charles has come here today to see
uh prince philip but on the other hand
uh you know we are told that
he is there in uh as of course measure
he did walk into the hospital when he
arrived here
on tuesday he didn't arrive by ambulance
or anything dramatic like that and and
we are told he's there just for
rest uh and observation so uh it look
does
it does look as if he will be here for
quite a few days to come they're told he
we're told he was going to stay over the
weekend and into next week
it says sources told pa on friday that
following a consultation with the doctor
the duke of edinburgh is likely to
remain in hospital for autism for the
rest of the weekend into next week
as we said previously the doctor acting
with an abundance of caution
and that duke remains in good spirits so
that's what we were told
uh on friday evening and uh
just it's just a slightly unusual thing
for
prince charles to turn up here and come
and see him especially
in these times of covid